والان مع اقتراب الحرب من اكمال عامها
الاول اعترف بوتا بالاخطاء من جهه لكنه
شدد على استعداد بلاده بحرب طويله الامد
او المره يقول فيها بوتن حرب بدلا من
عمليه عسكريه
لكن الحرب مهما طالت لا تنتهي الا بافتاح
العسكريين المجال امام السياسه ليقرروا
مصير الحرب على طاوله المفاوضات وبالحديث
يعني
عربوا السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه قدم
اقتراح الجديده الاحتكام الاستفتاء
النازيه للفصل النهائي في مستقبلي
اوكرانيا ممكن فقط في اطار النيتو وهكذا
يرى كاسانجير الوضع وفي المقابل يرى ان
اضعاف روسيا يشعل النزعه الانفصاليه في
البلاد اوكرانيا
وهي التي شرعت شرعت قانونا يجرم اصلا
الحوار مع روسيا لكن الوضع الان تغير
بحلول الشتاء
في السلام فريقه بصدد وضع اللمسات الاخيره
لخطه من 20 نقاط
كشفت الامر لكن التفاصيل لم تعلم بعد اكيد
انها لن تكون على شاكله اتفاقيه منسك
السياده الكامله شرطون اساسي الانفتاح على
المفاوضات جاء من واشنطن قبلها وبايدا
الذي وصف بوتا في بدايه الحرب المجرم
الجزار يبدو الان اكثر انفتاحا على الحوار
وناقش ذلك مع زلينس في خلال زيارته
لواشنطن موسكو فالشروطها لم تتغير
الخارجيه الروسيه ترفض كل فراق لا يعترف
بالواقع الذي فرضه الجيش الروسي على الارض
ووقفوا الدعم واشرطه العسكري لكيف شرطاسيه
بالعوده الى الاخطاء الروسيه الخاصه بوصول
الجنود الجبهات ونقص الامتداد المعنويات
من اهم المشاكل التي تواجه القياده وستزيد
المعاناه بالطبعا مع الانكودا تاييد زياده
حجم القوات المسلحه 30% وهنا اعتراف على
ما يبدو للقياده روسيه بالاخطاء وفي
محاوله للتصحيح روسيا اعادت قبل اشهر
احياء تقليدا يعود للجيش الامبراطوري
عندما ارسلت رجال الدين الى جبهه القتال
ولتربيه اذواق الجميع ها هي الان
تحيي تقليدا السوبيا
العثف على الالات الموسيقيه او الغناء
والتمثيل في روسيا لم يعد يقتصر الان على
المسارح فقط هذا الابداع له دور جديد وهام
الان رفع المعنويات لدى القوات الروسيه في
الخطوط الاماميه بمنطقه العمليه العسكريه
في اوكرانيا
لتجربه التي كانت خلال الحرب الوطني
العظمى وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تقرر تشكيله
فريقا من المبدعين من القوات التي تم
تعبئتها مؤخرا ومن الفنانين المحترفين
والممثلين
الذين ينضموا طواعيه الى الخدمه العسكريه
ليتم وضعهم في الخطوط الاماميه للحفاظ على
معنويات القوات الروسيه العاليه ووضعهم
النفسيه هناك